SPEAKER 1: Hope
is not a strategy
when it comes to security.
You have to approach
security from all angles
without a lot of burden
on dev or psych ops.
Not the easiest task.
But there's something on Google
Cloud that can go a long way.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
With an ever increasing
number of end points,
networks, and attack
surfaces, setting
automated and trickle-down
security policies
across your cloud infrastructure
can be a challenge
to say the least.
On top of that,
administrators want
to set guardrails to ensure
that their workloads are always
compliant to their security
requirements and industry
regulations.
Public IP are one
of the easiest ways
to expose your enterprise
environment to the internet,
so limiting public
IPs is paramount
when it comes to securing
your environments.
To do that, you
need to understand
what resources use public
IP is in your network,
and that can include VMs, load
balancers, and VPN gateways.
When you start to deploy
production level systems,
you're looking at thousands of
ways in which your developers
can open public IP addresses.
This is where organization
policies come into play.
Org policies give you
a centralized guardrail
over your organization's
Google Cloud resources.
As the Org policy
administrator, you
can configure restrictions
across your entire resource
hierarchy.
It works like this.
You can set Org policies on the
Org on folders or on projects.
They can be inherited by
nested folders and projects,
or they can be overwritten
on a case-by-case basis.
Using Org policies,
the Org admin
can enforce constraints
on Google Cloud resources
such as VMs and load balancers
to adhere to basic security
requirements at all times.
In this video,
we'll show you how
you can use Org
policies as guardrails
to ensure no public IPs are
allowed in your Google Cloud
network.
It's a perfect tool for
IT or security admins
to ensure all cloud deployments
adhere to their security
standards.
Let's dive into how you can
limit public IP exposure
for VMs, load balancers, and
VPN gateways using Org policies.
Compute Engine instances can
be exposed to the internet
directly when you assign
the VM a public IP,
or when you use
protocol forwarding
with the VM as its end point.
To prevent Compute
Engine instances
from getting public
IPs, first make
sure you have the Org policy
admin role on the organization
so you can add and
edit Org policies.
Then, under Org
policies, search for
and edit the Org policy
constraint constraints compute
VM external IP access.
This constraint lets you define
the set of Compute Engine
VMs that are allowed to use
public IPs on your network.
Meanwhile, all other VMs will
not be able to get a public IP.
Click Edit, select Customize,
replace the parent's policy
and use these roles, leave
the policy value as custom,
and set policy type as allow.
Then paste the path
to the only instance
you want to allow
external IP creation for.
Now you've restricted public IP
creation to only this instance
and prevented public IP
creation for any other instances
in your organization.
To prevent protocol
forwarding from being enabled,
use the Org policy constraint
constraints compute restrict
protocol forwarding
creation for types,
and set it to the
following values.
Note that the policy
value is case sensitive.
This constraint lets you limit
virtual hosting of public IPs
by Compute Engine VM instances
in your organization.
For VPNs, a VPN gateway requires
a public IP address for you
to connect your on premises
environment to Google Cloud.
To ensure that your VPN
gateway is protected,
use the Org policy
constraint constraints
compute restrict VPN peer IPs.
This constraint will
limit the public IPs
that are allowed to initiate
IPsec sessions with your VPN
gateway.
Next up, load balancers.
Google Cloud offers a variety
of internal and external load
balancers.
To prevent the creation of all
external load balancer types,
usually org policy
constraint constraints
compute restrict load
balancer creation for types,
and then make sure to add
all of these external load
balancer types for
the policy values.
And for ease of use, instead
of manually entering,
you can also simply
add in colon external,
which will always cover
all types of external load
balancers.
As new load balancer
types or introduced,
you can be assured your
infrastructure will
remain secure.
And finally, restricting
GKE surfaces.
GKE lets developers create
and expose their services
to the internet very easily.
But if you add the policies
for VMs and load balancers,
as we showed, no
new GKE services
can be exposed to the internet
without the organization
administrator's knowledge.
In this example, we've enabled
our Org policy constraints.
A developer attempts
to create a GKE service
with an external load balancer.
When we check the
status of the service,
they get a pending external IP.
When running kubectl
describe service,
they get an error due to
the load balancer Org policy
constraint in place.
Pretty sweet.
Keep in mind Org policies
are not retroactive.
They will only apply to
new infrastructure requests
after the policy is set.
So you won't have to worry about
breaking any existing workloads
when you add these
policies to your Org.
And that's it.
You can apply Org policies
easily and efficiently
across your entire Org
hierarchy or subset
of resources from a
single centralized place.
You can sleep better
at night knowing
you don't have any stray
resources that your teams have
assigned public IPs to
that shouldn't have them.
Check out the link
below to learn more.
And remember,
optimizing your network
means freeing up your bandwidth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]